in more than six hours of historic
testimony Robert Muller pushed back
against his critics including presidents
from the former Special Counsel appeared
before two congressional committees
yesterday he mainly stuck to the script
laid out in his written report Mahler
said Russian election interference
remains a threat and emphasized the
investigation did not exonerate the
President of the United States still mr.
Trump declared victory the Democrats had
nothing and now they have less than
nothing and I think they're gonna lose
the 20/20 election very big all right
Nancy Cordes was at those hearings and
she joins us now from Capitol Hill so
Nancy where do we go from here
well glad Democrats insist that they got
what they needed out of the day a chance
to highlight all of the president's
potential acts of obstruction of justice
but it does not appear that these
hearings prompted some new groundswell
of support for impeachment either here
on the hill or in the American public
writ large and that's something that
some of them had been hoping for this
was an important important important
hearing
Democrats declared the day a success
Republicans saw it differently I think
the problem is the Democrats didn't like
how he answered them so they're trying
to find a way to salvage something a
cautious former special counsel did not
give Democrats some of the impeachment
ammunition they were looking for we did
not reach a determination as to whether
the president committed a crime but he
did set the record straight the
president has repeatedly claimed that
your report found there was no
obstruction and that had completely and
totally exonerated him but that is not
what your report said is it correct it
is not what the report says Republicans
argued that Muller's report left mr.
Trump under a cloud of suspicion with no
way to clear his name why don't we have
all of this investigation of President
Trump that the other side is talking
about when you knew that you weren't
going to prosecute him you don't know
where the investigations gonna lie
Donald Trump is not above the law
he's not but he damn sure shouldn't be
below the law which is where volume 2 of
this report
Tim Muller was considered a reluctant
witness over the course of six hours he
offered one-word answers 176 times yes
no tread but it was clear about the
chances of more Russian interference did
you find evidence to suggest they'll try
to do this again oh it wasn't a single
attempt they're doing it as we sit here
and defended his investigation against
the president's attack well your
investigation is not a witch-hunt is it
is not on which I the president wanted
to fire you because you were
investigating him for obstruction of
justice isn't that correct that's what
it says in the report yes and I go I
stand by the report House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi called the date historic but
wouldn't say if it had nudged her closer
to impeachment even after these hearings
the president said he's completely
exonerated we want to have the strongest
possible case to make a decision as to
what path we will go down
speaker Pelosi added that Democrats are
going to continue to fight the president
in the courts as their probes into his
finances go on and late last night the
House Judiciary Committee announced that
it's going to go to court today to
enforce a subpoena against former White
House Counsel Don Magan who was a
central figure in the Muller report Yael
Nancy thank you very much